I get up at 07:30 if I have to shower,
if not at 8 o'clock I make my coffee,
I take my Maria cookies and walk
to work or by bicycle,
it depends on where you live,
maybe you will find one.
Yes.
We don't want to arrive sweaty either.
I go to work as my computer,
I check all the emails and start answering.
I see my list of things I have to do for the day,
then today I will go to lunch around 12:30,
I take 1 hour to eat
and after this process you continue to work for 1 day
that there is nothing to do.
At 05:30 we started to leave,
if I have 1 little more work
you can stay until 06:06 and 2nd and then
the reeds famous for Brussels.
Obviously
Belgian culture rules and let's go take it
1 Belgian beer for
celebrate that we are in this city
and the weather is getting good
and when it gets bad then